[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show
tragic news from canada where a mass
shooting has left 16 dead of gunmen
disguised as a police officer shot
people in their homes and set fires
across the province of Nova Scotia this
is the deadliest such attack in Canada's
history the suspected shooter is also
dead one police officer is among the
dead and several bodies were found
inside and outside a home in the town of
porta peak which is about 60 miles north
of Halifax bodies also found elsewhere
this was an assault that lasted a long
time it started late Saturday and the
belief right now is that the first
victims were targeted and then the
attacker started just going after people
randomly although as always in these
situations it's still early we don't yet
know all of the details a residents of
Porter peak were put on lockdown well
they were sort of already on lockdown
because of the pandemic they were put on
extra lockdown because of the mass
shooter that was out there told to stay
in their basements home started to be
set on fire the individual has been
identified as a 51 year old man believed
to live part time in porta peak he wore
a police uniform at one point during
this fiasco made his car look like an
RCMP cruiser and just an absolutely
horrible and senseless act of violence
we of course don't know all about the
motivation or anything like that what we
do know is that mass shootings are far
more rare in Canada than they are here
so you know I feel like we're reacting
pat with our American sensibility to
mass shootings but because we're so
accustomed to them tragically if you
consider how rare these are in Canada
this is almost impossible to believe
yes 16 killed in this incident contrast
that to the greatest shooting in
American history which was the Las Vegas
shooting and that was 58 people so many
times more
and you know when this whole corona
virus pandemic started I thought that
maybe one of the silver linings would be
that there would be fewer mass shootings
because of course people aren't out in
public they're not able to gather in
schools and movie theaters and bars and
the types of places well you'll you'll
see mass shootings take place but this
person unfortunately found a way to do
it and part of the reason I think he was
able to do it was because everyone was
at home and he knew that everyone was at
home and if you're in this small village
you're able to sort of go from house to
house without being found out for a
little while it seems and that's how he
was able to get away with it absolutely
and completely tragic and then of course
now all of the you know there's I fear
that if there are if there's start to be
incidents like this in the United States
I fear that it will be used by those who
want to prop up Trump to say hey look
Trump was right the effects of the
quarantine may be worse than the effects
of the virus and of course it's totally
post hoc reasoning but Trump completely
wildly suggested a couple of times once
you consider suicide and drug addiction
staying home may actually be worse than
the effects of letting the virus run its
course and every serious person public
health officials said at the time that's
not right that's absolutely crazy but
certainly when you're talking about
hundreds of millions of people
situations can cause people to do things
that they wouldn't otherwise do and I
worry that if this starts up here and
even this incident in Canada may start
to be used to scapegoat stay at home in
social distancing guidelines yeah I mean
there certainly are negative
externalities to the decisions that
we're making right now telling everyone
to stay at home and they could see how
that may lead to more depression more
suicide but I think that the right wing
is trying to use those negative
externalities to say that oh we should
just go back to normal people need to go
back to work which of course isn't the
right solution it's it's kind of like
whenever there's a mass shooting like
this one and conservatives go out and
start talking about the importance of
mental health certainly we have to pay
more attention to that you know make
sure that people who have trouble have
access to treatment that's a sort of
thing but it can't be used as a red
herring to distract from the broader
issue here which is actually trying to
regulate the guns it's actually gun
violence itself that's the issue in
the mental health thing is sort of a
secondary issue but they sort of a are
able to blur the lines when they do that
oh very much so very much so when we
look at what's going on with
universities there's sort of there's
elementary in high schools and then
there's universities that we have to
think about when it comes to the virus
there are still discussions of could
some elementary or high schools reopen
this semester
some of them go until late June and
could some open May 1st May 1st to the
end of June or May 15th I think it's
crazy to even think about that I think
that at this point they just need to
remain closed school districts need to
figure out what's going to happen in
terms of do people have to stay back or
not I think the answer is probably not
you you I think the situation is the
situation is so unique we've got to
figure out a way to if they're high
school seniors we've got to get them
graduated if they are elementary school
kids we've got to figure out a way to
get them on to the next year you know
holding everyone back and reopening both
seem like bad ideas I think that's got
to be figured out yeah we got to be gone
through the rest of the semester I think
that's very clear cuz you know best-case
scenario this stuff the first wave of
this pandemic wraps up in early June and
that's usually around the time when you
start wrapping up for summer break
anyway so I think for this semester
we're done so then we get to next
semester I don't know what elementary
schools and high schools are going to do
because starting the year remotely via
teleconference would be very difficult
what I am seeing is that many colleges
and universities my mom teaches at one I
have friends who teach at multiple other
colleges here in the Boston area
they've all been advised and this is
just a handful but they've all been
advised and more schools are doing this
that the fall semester may be happening
online it's going to happen but it's
gonna be happening remotely and online
for people just starting college this is
going to be tough that's the reality
it's very tough to start college in a
digital format but increasingly there
are more schools thinking about we may
not be back in person until the spring
of 2021 semester which would be about
nine to ten months from now I don't
totally think it's crazy I think it's
horrible
Pat but when you consider that you meet
the amount of infrastructure you need to
either get these millions of students
into their dorms or not is huge the
of decisions that have to be made very
soon about physical plant and staffing
and and food at dining halls and all of
this stuff it's not clear we won't be in
a second wave at the start of that
semester of the fall semester or that if
we aren't that one will be going by
October or November
it doesn't seem crazy to me as sad as it
is yeah we should at least have the
contingency plans on the table right we
may not necessarily have to make the
final decisions yet but I think they
should have backup plans in place and
the biggest concern I'd have to imagine
is like the labs right the sciences
because I went to school for Political
Science so I would have been able I
think to do all my classes via zoom and
you know just do all my work online I
think I would have been able to make it
through just fine but if I was like a
science major if I had to be in a bio
lab every day you just can't do that
remotely you have to actually be there
and you actually have to be like testing
the stuff in the lab if they can't do
that for another year or so I mean
that's gonna hold some people back no
doubt about it
and I think that there's also broader
questions about you know the there have
been discussions of delaying altogether
like just saying don't even start let's
just wait incoming classes should just
be delayed I actually do think that
listen if it's not the end nothing is
the end of the world until the end of
the world right and so with that sort of
fo optimistic mindset it in in mind this
might be a good time to actually get
going on a degree in the sense that
delaying it will put you in a worse
position when things do get going when
the jobs do start coming back my
instinct is let's figure out a way to
use technology to keep people learning
and moving forward that's my instinct
yeah there's nothing else to do right
fewer distractions that - no you wanted
to get a new degree or even if you
wanted to like take up a new language or
learn a new instrument I think now is
the time to do it because we have so
much free time right now seize the day
seize the day now let me mention one
other thing before we move on to the to
the housecat story I've been thinking
about a lot of what you know with a lot
of these protesters that are protesting
the lockdowns right if you actually lost
your job there are programs in place
including enhanced unemployment plus the
stimulus checks
although the stimulus checks are you
know for a lot of people's budgets not
really enough there's gonna have to be
more
there are some things there for people
who have straight up a loss their jobs
and a lot of the protesters have not
actually lost their jobs but they're
protesting the fact that things are
closed and shut down so not to placate
the protesters in any way because
there's all of my friends are staying
home but still they want to feel like
we're making progress are there little
ways that we might be able to feel as
though we're making progress like let me
give you a dumb little example right
for the most part restaurants in Boston
have not closed but they are takeout and
delivery only and some of them have
pretty good setups where you order
online or off your phone or call it's
all paid for you walk in you can't get
anywhere near the staff they put the
bags of takeout on a table and then you
just look for your name and you grab the
bag and you leave brilliant there's no
contact whatsoever as it starts to get
warmer couldn't it be done if the curve
starts turning around that you can also
have the food left if the place has
tables out back for example very widely
spaced out they put your takeout on the
table
you have no interaction with the staff
but you're allowed to sit there and eat
it is this something that could provide
a psychological benefit just the idea
that like okay there's normally 20
tables in the patio they're only gonna
put four and you've got to bring your
own drinks because they're not gonna
serve you water but you're allowed to
sit there then you leave and they
sanitize like it's it's so little but if
people are already going in and out of
the restaurants for take-out maybe the
risk is very low and it would make
people feel like we're moving in the
right direction maybe the risk isn't
worth it I don't know well we know it's
gonna be a slow transition so I do think
we'll see things like that I mean that
that instance in particular may be kind
of difficult you'd have to get the staff
to go and sanitize the table and the
chairs every single time to make sure
that there's no transmissions happening
but yeah I mean that would be what I
think we want to to go towards also like
with beaches maybe they'll be able to
open some beaches pretty soon as long as
they limit the number of people as long
as people are spread out because I feel
like in a vast Beach setting where you
have all the sand and water and stuff it
doesn't seem all that likely that the
disease would transmit you know it's
maybe than it would but if it's if not
it's not populated maybe you'd be able
to open the beaches they're talking
about like movie theaters even and like
supporting venues coming back open but
you would want to be able to like spread
the people out yeah maybe you wouldn't
have concessions open so I think that's
gonna be what we see take place over the
course of the summer those sorts of
things start to reopen and maybe that
will satisfy people maybe that will get
people to start paying attention to the
rules and staying inside most of the
time and get them off the streets and
stop protesting my view on this is not
informed by what I think is the safest
thing it's informed by the realization
that the tolerance for months and months
of this is just not there both from
people and politicians like politicians
also I don't think are going to have the
political will to political capital to
suspend keeping things closed as public
opinion turns more and more against that
which it will so so like I want to be
really clear this isn't me saying I
think we should do all this stuff right
away
it's the fact that I've recognized that
it's going to happen and what's the
safest way to do it so like another
another example would be so best-case
scenario we get to 500,000 tests a day
we're now doing about 150 a hundred and
fifty thousand a day you you've got to
get to 500 thousand a day you start to
see some states actually decline and
then you say we're gonna do something
what are some of the elements that can
be done and I think you know these
limited restaurant things may be part of
it I don't know what else would be part
of it but my thought process is I
wouldn't be surprised if by June 1 many
states have somewhat loosened guidelines
my hope is they will do it in the
slowest most responsible way possible
yeah and we've talked about how we've
started to get used to this like this is
just a new normal this is the routine
no more commuting maybe we'll go on a
walk that sort of thing but we're paying
attention to the rules and we've kind of
gotten used to it yeah I think that's
true for now but once the summer kicks
in and you know you can feel the heat
outside and people want to be outside
and one of the beaches and all that
stuff I think people's feelings about
this all what will change pretty quickly
and that's why when I see stories about
stuff being closed into the fall it
depresses me so much because I can deal
with this for like a couple months but
beyond that it's gonna get
more difficult I think it's going to be
I think that a lot of people a lot of
states have already said and the ones
that that haven't are expected to say
we're going to May 15 and I think that
that may be the limit for a lot of
people temper mentally and then it's
going to become a real problem with the
nicer weather in parts of the country no
doubt about it
okay let's talk about house cats we've
talked before about the impact of house
cats that kill migratory birds and other
critters mice sometimes rats etc and
there's a new study which calculates
that house cats can have four to ten
times the impact of a wild predator on
the ecosystem in which they live and the
reason why is not that they do a lot
more killing but because they do it in a
much more concentrated area and
therefore on a percentage basis if you
imagine a little cat that does a lot of
damage in a three by three block radius
compared to imagine a some larger
predator that is certainly doing more
killing but they're doing it over an
area of many square miles you are on a
percentage basis affecting a larger
share of the ecosystem in that little
box in which the house cat is being a
predator so we're learning a lot Pat
about truly the effect of house cats on
the ecosystems here yeah is the solution
to just keep the cats inside make them
indoor cats I mean that doesn't seem
very fair to the cat if they spent half
their life being able to go outside and
around in the neighborhood and then you
lock them up for the remainder of their
lives but that may be the best thing for
the environment for the ecosystem
unfortunately the there's other ideas
like for example you put really brightly
colored collars on your cat because then
when they approach predators the
Predators seem to run away much more
quickly they noticed that that actually
does seem to be working it's reducing
the number of birds that some cats bring
home yeah maybe you could attach a bell
to the collar of the cat although I
believe that worked less what they tried
that the studies was that that didn't
actually work that well when I was
living at my parents house we had a cat
there and I said we should have a collar
on this cat so that you know people who
may come across
sir will know that she's owned by
someone and you know we could put the
information so in case you gets lost
they can return and the the consensus
was that you don't want to put a collar
on the cat because that could cause them
to get stuck like if they're trying to
get through a narrow space at their
training roll through a fence or
something that the caller may get them
stuck because they only adjust they only
are able to assess if they're able to
get into a place based on like the the
width of their head and their neck right
so if it's a little bit longer because
of the collar they're not gonna be able
to account for that and so that's one
reason why you may not have that collar
on the cap there's a SIA is it not
typical to microchip a cat the way that
you would a dog is that not really done
I think it should be done if it's not
typical they should make that happen
because that that you do like by
surgically inserting something into the
Hat right it's not attached to the call
yeah I would love to have that I would
love to see where my old cat went
because I know it was famous for going
all around the neighborhood right and I
think that that's the type of tracking
that was done for this study that looked
at where where cats were going so that's
the news does this in any way affect
your view as a vegan on cat ownership
well yeah I mean I feel like there's no
winning here because you either keep the
cat inside and then the cat feels
trapped like it can't go out and explore
the world and we don't want to see that
if you let the cat outside than so many
birds and chipmunks and mice are gonna
die so like there's really no winning
here I suppose the only solution is to
not have a cat but who would who would
want to deal with that I mean I don't
know it's unimaginable not to have a cat
in your mind unimaginable and this
actually reminds me of the story that
took place when I was living at my dad's
house with the cat and one time I let
the cat in it was outside and I was
going to bed and usually the cat would
sleep with me in the bed and so I open
up the door to let the cat inside and it
just darts up the staircase up to my
bedroom and I'm like oh that's kind of
weird usually she'll like want to come
in and eat something and then like
slowly she'll she'll make her way up to
the bedroom and I was like all right
that's that's kind of interesting so I
get ready for bed I'm lying in bed and I
see the cat like show up and instead of
crawling up into the bed with me as she
usually does she was just kind of
hanging out next to the bed on the floor
clearly preoccupied with something and
I'm like what's going on what's going on
with Miss Muffet right now so I turn on
the light and sure enough
she's just bowing down on a bird that
she had brought inside
yes as a gift to me I don't know but it
was not the type of thing that you want
to see at midnight and yes I did shriek
and yes I did yell at the cat which
caused the cats who run out the door
with the bird in its mouth so that was
not the most pleasant situation how did
you ultimately get rid of the bird that
you did the cat bring it back outside or
did you 'evil it luckily the cat brought
it back outside once it realized that it
was not happy with it for bringing me
this gift it knew what was going on and
took it outside with it so I was very
happy about that I don't know that much
about cats but I've heard about them
bringing dead animals to their owners is
it I don't know what the psychological
element of it is but it seems to be
common yeah maybe because we owners do
so much for the cats that's the way that
they reciprocate if only they knew that
we don't actually want those dead birds
in dead mice they would stop killing
them and then we wouldn't have a problem
like this where they're killing all the
wildlife I think they just have to
communicate the message to them Wow well
if only it was easier to communicate
with a cat that has been one of my
struggles I find it much easier to
communicate with a dog than a cat and
that that's probably why I'm more of a
dog person all right that does it for
today we will be back tomorrow new show
new bonus show the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]